[funky hip-hop music]
- [yawns]
- Yo, why you look
so tired, my dude?
- Stayed up late
watching "New Jack City."
That joint got
fire-ass quotables.
- [as Wesley Snipes]
Sit your $5-ass down
before I make change.
- "Never liked you anyway,
pretty mother[bleep]."
[laughter]
- Bro, Wesley Snipes the GOAT--
"White Men Can't Jump,"
"Passenger 57,"
"To Wong Foo, Thanks for
Everything, Julie Newmar."
- Man, how you gonna name
that "Wong Foo" shit
and not drop "Jungle Fever?"
Y'all don't know shit.
- Yeah, "Jungle Fever"
was my shit.
[as Snipes]
Mama, I smoked the TV.
[laughs]
Now pay attention
to the goddamn game!
- Damn Milk,
I didn't know
"Jungle Fever"
meant so much to you.
- Yeah, we enjoy watching
Snipes take down Beckys
as much as anybody.
No need to get
testy with Wesley.
- My bad, y'all.
I'm tripping.
Uncle Joey got
my shit twisted.
- What'd you do now, Milk?
- He on some ole
"send me away" 'cause
my YouTube show
about to blow shit.
- You got a YouTube show?
What's it called?
[whooshing]
- "Got You, Mother[bleep]!"
- [humming]
[air dryer blows]
[coughing]
You put baby powder
in my blow dryer?
- Nah, I put blow
in your blow dryer.
- What?
- [laughs]
Got you, mother[bleep].
- [gibbering]
[thud]
[fantastical whoosh]
Milton, get down here; we're
gonna be late for synagogue.
[squish]
The hell?
Is this honey?
Why would--Milton!
[mower revving]
- Got you, mother[bleep].
[sputtered screaming]
[bees buzzing]
[fantastical whoosh]
- Get out the car,
you cracker-ass cracker,
and leave the shit running.
- Please, don't hurt me.
- Knew you was a
mark-ass bitch, caa!
- Milton!
[tires squealing]
[crash]
- G--got you, moth...
- That's it,
Milton!
You're out!
[whooshing]
- So that square
Uncle Joey booted me,
signed me up for the
student exchange program.
- Oh, for real?
Foreign breezies love Americans.
Where he sending you?
France, Japan, Swedish?
- Man, [blows raspberry]
Ubombastan.
- Damn, Milk.
- Well, I'm finna
just pour out
a little something
for you now.
- What's that
supposed to mean?
- It means you better
learn how to throw rocks
'cause you dead,
mother[bleep]!